bello e tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa vigente la gestiamo
suo happy days ragazzi che sono un gioco
simile molto simile a cat mario è un po
più splatter credo va bene che possiamo
cominciare agazzi la scelta nella lingua
e fondamentale quindi fans ecco
l'effetto è già non capisco un cazzo che
ebbe la grafica che c è la madonna che
poi il meglio che si sta guardando il
braccio che tipo a chiazze ragazzi
diciamo che è meglio partire prima che
diventi tragico facciamo suardi a tre
livelli solo
vabbè dai facciamo il primo che beh
perché scelto francese ragazzi non
capisco una serie un bel giorno nè come
ho capito no mesti alla ideal ha idee
l'hai detto prima farm elenco tua o
vieni sympathy di merda sono il capitolo
avanti ma che ancora non ho capito il
senso visto gioco si può coniglietto
piccola re perché un coniglietto mi ha
squartato le budella vera è continuerà
ragazzi continua come si salta è così
salter pefette suker succhiar sta minkia
succhia sta minkia e tv cat mario o
supermario semplicemente però tanto so
che c'è una trappola inutile che mi fate
prendere per il culo
invece no non so e non è normale stavo
scherzando pudende tam e come si salterà
così cos'è il parterre
ecco profeta che howard che napoleone ha
fatto casino per molto meno e sesto
gioco mi fa incazzare [ __ ] sa che
sei francese mi6 su katzer fantastiche
le magnifiche le cade dal soffitto e
valassi [ __ ]
no no no no fottutamente parole per la
canzone ragazzi però va bene se non si
trova un chilo passava bene avevo
impiegato 45 anni per finire il primo
episodio di primo livello di cat mario
ragazzi allora sono molto prima li che
cazzo ci voglio di nuovo bravo trio
bravo uno zio noti deve esplodere il
fratello no bravo zio brava posso
scendere questa canzone vista sul culo
in maniera no perché ma che cazzo fa
ragazzi ci sono esattamente tre livelli
di questa merda tracy come dice il buco
ragazzi vado qui sotto ecco mica
lasciato il gioco non cambia un cazzo
perché tanto è come se avessi cioè non
ci sono i salvataggi in sta merda quindi
uguale ok ok via no io cado ii tronco 1
tronco nicchia 2
ok adesso sull'erbetta sull'erbetta
lerman ok se fuma ti permetta fumati la
beta genitori il coniglio con le mette
no ragazzi sentite io vivi su no no no
perché perché perché il terzo tronco
l'erbetta knoller better deals al toro
non ha saltato dove può saltare in non
ha saltato
dovevo saltare in un assaltato dovevo
salta adesso le armetta c'è dove salto
sull'altra smetta sull'altra diveniamo
di erbette nolo perché l'erbetta non
funziona qual è il problema di queste
madonna che mi sono salvato che cazzo
faccio adesso
dove vado cazzo si sono come lo sui cani
mi ha salvato il culo si vede la
trappola cazzo ma no non ci credo si
vedeva ma ditelo prima riga ma che ne so
io ciao fratello come stai a mazzè anche
tu conigli nel tempo libero senti ziona
ferfina più amico o nemico se la capra
di go simulator fra teso toccarti mi fai
qualcosa posso toccare amico amico
perfetto meno male che amico bravo così
con la lingua succhiami culo
probabilmente se muoio riparto da quel
tizio probabilmente così credo spero
prego porca [ __ ] e non c'è poi quindi
non ricomincerò dall'inizio non c'è poi
no ma perché no da schifo di merda di
giorno no non ho veramente no sono
caduto di nuovo lì i ragazzi sono caduto
di nuovo lì era così bello che mai
voglio rifare voglio che tu mario
ragazzi voglio giocare hackett mario non
mi sta rompendo le palle sta roba dov'è
la trappola l'altra e qualche si vede
perfetto e qua o volo o non ci arrivo
non è possibile ma da il salto air
vogliono una mazza da cricket e il
coniglio sarà il coniglio c'era conigli
se sei cazzo ok calmi che cazzo guardi
calmissimi calmi devi morire e devi
morire se sul tronco c'è qualcosa mi
incazzo non c'è niente il creatore di
questo gioco si alza la mattina e dice
ma che bello perché lo creiamo una merda
con la quale possa giocare fa vj una
cargo a caso proprio un gioco di merda
caso così dove c'è uno che si salva col
culo cosa vuoi che faccia dalla mia vita
spiega melo può saltare oltre saltiamo
oltre bene adesso ammazzo al coniglio
mentre cado si no la trappola cazzo
c'era la fine no c'era la fine ma non ci
voglio marco mi sono morto alla fine un
passo devo farne un ok ok se muoio c'è
[Musica]
lippi e tuo zio
non so come descrivere sta roba assurda
mai più di un emmy beh significa è il
caramello tu passi più duro dell'idea
che è una marca comte 3 amherd cosa
semplice che cazzo e su c'è qualcuno mi
spieghi cosa è successo e fammi partita
e karma donna
[Musica]
con calma su chiamerò non ha senso la
vita no regalano gli fai fare due metri
due anni ok ok adesso visto che è il
secondo cubo sarà una trappola sicuro a
vado sul terzo perché japan tukul
perfetta nei comet i esplodo la famiglia
coniglio del cazzo no bravo a ascolta
sul secondo si bene no devi saltare di
saltare se prendo questo tasto qui hai
sempre saltato numero premuto ok quindi
devi saltare bravo di nuovo bravo bravo
sia capito ha capito calmi perfetto ok 1
ok 2 anno devo andare di sopra perfetto
ma credo che non debba andare di sopra e
vabbè che bordello rega ok ok
sì sì sì ok non vado non ci vado
non ci vado a non ci vado ragazzi non ci
vadano queste quella buona ragazzino
sento che quella buona
me lo sento la trappola è questa quindi
l'assalto vado qua
siccome intenso cubo prima era la
trappola adesso sarà il secondo quindi
bados di nuovo sul terzo
e invece no è invece no i miei
ragionamenti da bradipo non funzionano
un pene non c'è verso mai nella vita di
fare sto gioco impossibile dove cazzo
vado di mi dovete con di melo o europea
robe a caso un po no no no non sto
facendo non soccombere che annuncia farò
medici e il prossimo episodio dai dai
dai dai no tenetevi pronti che arriva
presto